systems are now open nominations are now
open for the eighth annual heart of
Education Awards and they honor our
hard-working CCSD teachers for their
outstanding work and here to talk about
the awards or Myron Martin CEO and
president of the Smith Center good
morning to you and a music teacher and
past education winner Tyler swick Tyler
very nice to meet you congratulations
thank you so much I can tell you're
still basking in the glow oh yeah
previously winning absolutely oh wow
absolutely congratulations I'm going to
ask Myron first why is it so important
that we recognize our teachers here at
CCSD well
teachers are the kinds of people who
don't think about themselves right they
care about their kids they care about
the art of teaching and it was about
time that somebody turned their
spotlights on the teachers themselves
and we all as a community said thank you
oh that's fantastic in the part of
Education Awards this is the eighth year
for it now how much money I mean this is
some grand grand prize money well it is
I mean people like Tyler walk home with
a big check for five thousand dollars
and their programs go home with with
checks as well this year the heart of
Education Awards will go over a million
dollars in total funding direct to
teachers which makes us really happy
that's fantastic uh Tyler we're looking
at you uh getting the announcement and
it was during the pandemic so tell us
how you found out this was in 2020. well
my lovely principal Dr Hall you can see
on the screen uh lied to me and said
that we were doing interviews for CCSD
we're going to hire some new music
teachers and I thought my expertise was
needed which I thought was a flattery in
itself and then Myron shows up and I go
well this guy's a he's not going to be
you know he's a new teacher I guess okay
and so if I I looked a little confused
in the video I was I was confused and I
was quite emotional it was an incredible
recognition of all the things that have
gone on imagine what it was like for me
to pop into their Zoom meeting and say
hey by the way you won the heart of
Education award this year it was very
cool very cool and you teach at Ellis
Elementary School it's your fifth year
so uh you won five thousand dollars
that's the personal award that goes to
the winners and a thousand dollars for
the a program of your choice at the
school where'd you put the money uh I
put the five thousand dollars towards
renovating my home studio for teaching
from home I won the middle of our
quarantine so it was a fantastic time to
win because during one of the darkest
times of teaching is incredible
acknowledgment comes in and I'm
incredibly grateful the Rogers
foundation and the Smith Center for that
uh and so I spent the five thousand on
making sure the computer and the cameras
are all looking great and then the
thousand dollars went to uh creating a
drumline at our school which I'm happy
to say is gonna be playing a silver
Knights home games soon oh my gosh
that's fantastic congratulations thank
you very much well we have to talk about
quickly the importance of writing the
letters and nominating a teacher that's
the thing right now is the time where
you can nominate a teacher for the heart
of Education Awards it only takes a
minute you go online you go to the Smith
Center's website and you say something
nice about a teacher and here's the
beauty of it not only do the winners
hear that they won something but
everyone who's nominated gets an email
saying someone said this really nice
thing about you it's I call them love
letters and and the teacher's inboxes
because sometimes they don't realize the
parents and other teachers and the lunch
lady down the hallway see them as
mentors and people that Inspire them so
it's great for them to hear this that's
fabulous all right the deadline is
January 20th so get your nominations in
kids parents neighbors everybody and
then you'll celebrate them all and the
winners will be announced in April is
that right it'll be announced in April
and it'll be teachers like this who go
above and beyond thank you both for
being here it was great to meet you I
know
you're admired for being here thank you
Tyler our